you know we on stages you don't see
nothing because of the lights I don't
see nothing because I'm there but I'm
not really let's go it's not so odd
about this is urgent rush the world
think they know tomorrow but they
haven't seen came on yet okay miss I
really have to go what time is it
everybody chillax I got this I've been
dreaming of this moment since I was a
little girl
but it's a lot of pressure Tamar is
doing Dancing with the Stars how is that
gonna work out with my album you say you
want to be booked my schedules out of
control as you can see I just left my
first for her so far Dancing with the
Stars they'll be getting nervous and
that's what I'm nervous about so could
be he gets pushy [ __ ] owning a little
secret I'm nervous sometimes artists can
get lost and wanting things to be
perfect where's the choreographer
where's my damn stylist is a
perfectionist you sick no not I feel
amazing you don't want to push it cuz
you don't know what I've been gone
through I gotta take a deep breath and
get it done
are you read I don't remember nothing
find out what really happened on the new
season of Tamar and Vince Thursday
December tent at nine on WE TV